braun hailer did you get the chance to
play call duty beta at all no I did not
unfortunately but I did get to comb
through a lot of footage of a Eric tail
over here playing it I'm more into your
guys opinions I mean you know how it
plays is something completely different
than from what I've seen but it looks
like you know looks like hot yeah I mean
it's it's weird cuz its infinity ward
the last game the release was ghosts and
that was kind of following the whole
thing with a respawn forming with vince
zampella jason west and grant cali left
and so this could you know theoretically
be their first game to put them back on
the map like i'm sure that's what
they're hoping because ghost was kind of
not received all that well the
multiplayer was a little bit stale the
campaign same thing but uh so this is
the first chance the i think tomorrow it
goes wide to the public on ps4 is either
tomorrow or today but right now it's
closed beta and you and i played we
streamed at yesterday Eric what are your
overall thoughts so far how does it feel
much to what Rob said it's kind of like
another Cod there are like little layers
of differences i guess like the double
jump while running stuff they kind of
had already in advanced warfare so
they're kind of like tweaking that i
like a little bit and then now there's
rigs instead of specialists like in
black ops 3 so there's a little bit more
to that kind of game player that system
that they've they've kind of gone with
so every rig has like you know three
payloads or two or three payloads which
is kind of like a I know Peters gonna
hate me for saying this place like a
special ability usually like an ultimate
even though they're called payloads and
then they all have traits of which do
different things so each character does
different things and certain abilities
will probably play better for certain
like game types and whatnot so it's just
I guess another extra layer but it's not
that different and then the the weapons
you can craft them now which is slightly
different or get them in boxes which you
do like quests or just log in daily and
you get keys and you open them and you
just hope to god you get a
epic I guess which the loot crate system
is kind of pervasive intruders now I
mean overwatch has had a big dealers
like the aesthetic the skins and the
emotes and whatnot earlier this year
titanfall i'm not sure what they're
gonna have yet battle but battlefield
one has the battle packs that's very
similar you get skins you get new
weapons and that's kind of become this
thing where it's almost a gamble right i
mean obviously you don't have to spend
real world money if you don't want to
but it's kind of like the more time you
invest the more chance you have at
getting whatever you want i guess um did
we get anything i got an epic so it's
like a kind of like the traditional like
diablo doesn't he loop it's like a blue
weapon purple and then orange or the
epics I got an epic for a weapon and
then I didn't actually have the weapon
itself unlocked until like level 20 or
something yeah so it didn't matter at
least in the beta it didn't know if
that's going to change but you also have
these factions right are what they call
the mission teams yeah so there's like
the Wolverines as other factions can you
swine how those work um so I didn't go
too in depth with them but it just seems
like they're kind of like your faction
that you like pledge your allegiance to
so to speak you get missions from him to
do certain objectives within the game
that you're playing so it's like
headshots or like double kills or you
know payload kills or something like
that and every time you do that you
slowly love like so you have two things
you're leveling right you're leveling
your core level which allows you to
access more guns and gear and stuff like
that as well as the rigs and then you
have kind of your faction which also
unlocks like guns and stuff like that so
and I think he gives you keys and
salvage and materials and stuff like
that so it's just kind of getting you to
do all these little extra like almost
like bounties like in destiny so it's
like oh while you're playing the game
try to get headshots you get headshots
you'll level up your faction reputation
and you'll get benefits from it kind of
a little layer it's like they just added
even more layers to the progression like
every single shooter does now I feel
like maybe not every single but a lot of
the military shooters do that right now
you have mission teams worried about you
have the legendary weapons and the
crafting to think about you have just
these I mean obviously you're unlikely
things like call signs of what not but
you're like aesthetic things for your
the different rigs so the rig's not to
keep like pointing out hero shooters or
mobile buzzes but like it's that's kind
of becoming think it's titanfall 2 has
the mech are the Titans themselves are
like characters now with superpowers
rather than heavier light with specific
loadouts that people are going to go for
but
we can get into that like probably next
week more titanfall 2 but it is it's
kind of this ubiquitous thing now where
the the hero shooters kind of invading
military shooters now because like the
rigs like specialist in black ops 3 were
kind of the inception of this idea with
column duty right you had these
different characters that you could
recognize them and know that sparrows
longbow is pretty dangerous if you see
the sonar pulse you know she's kind of
like picking out people with radar and
whatnot it's not only about how you play
those characters about how to know how
to counter them have you found that to
be pretty deep in the beta so far um I
didn't notice it as much as like you
would like an overwatch but I mean
obviously when you see someone and have
their payload out especially if it's
like a weapon type like based one you
definitely want to try to kill them as
fast as possible or run away or try to
get to a spot word like your team can
team fire them sure so like you know if
sin app is a synaptic Orson that I
always an optic synaptic he can go into
that like kind of robot dog mode right
where he basically a wall wall run or
running on the ground and then he 11
shots he with melee but he has to get
pretty close to you to do that so like
if you can get away or use some of the
movement mechanics that are in the game
to get away then hopefully there's some
of that I guess but in terms of like
hard countering some stuff I haven't
seen it but if you read some of the
tooltips they do say hey this it's like
certain traits and stuff like that will
like hard count or something else I
haven't seen it in terms of like the
payloads necessarily but I'm sure like
if your FTL if you have like essentially
like the golden gun right like if you
see erasers erasers yes re the eraser if
you see you know someone else with you
know the the steel warhead or whatever
like you can you shoot them and like
that's how you deny it's kind of how it
was in black ops 3 in order to I think
one thing like a lot of people are
curious about I don't know how much
you've seen it yet Rob but I think
people saw that they said they might be
like using the low gravity in cool ways
or multiple or at least we hope they
would but now right now on them what's
the map that in close quarters on teams
here it's like this these hallways and
sight lines and I like the map because
it's cool how like it kind of folds in
on itself underneath certain hallways
but it's this spaceship hall and like
every time someone dies they just float
into the air but that seemed to be the
case for a lot of the maps but my
actually my question was going to be our
different maps like do they have to
like forms of gravity or heightened
gravity and some of them because it felt
like every time you were doing a double
jump or a floaty jump it's just it
looked like a mannequin was kind of like
flying around the map it was just a
weird something that I feel like for a
card game I've never seen before light
well it's weird cuz in this I can't
remember for the life of me and black
ops 3 did you also have to kind of hold
the boost button to do the double jump
as opposed to titanfall reached tabak
toys right now you kind of to use up the
whole meter it's like this meter use up
and while running uses a double jumping
use it sliding a little bit black ops 3
head a little bit more like a feather to
it like you could kind of get a little
more out of it like you it was a little
more controlled goes to a hard second
jump cuz this right now it says it too
same thing this right now it's you have
to like hold it a little bit to use the
whole double jump and not yeah that kind
of worries me because I don't want my
thumb to be there I want it to be on the
analog stick ready to aim at somebody um
I'm because if you just let go you're
not gonna do the full height of your
jump and if you need that full height to
vault over something or get to this wall
to run down it can I no worries me it's
a minor mechanic I'm sure it wouldn't
affect the overall game too much but it
feels good in general same thing with
the the ground ass you have to kind of
hold general or circular know what she
is blowing when you're sprinting and
everything but that's the one thing I
haven't seen this is just the beta the
game we got one of our editors is
reviewing it right now but obviously he
can't talk about it yet it releases a
early November but right now it doesn't
seem like they're using the future
aesthetic there to make the maps
actually interesting I mean I like the
rigs and I like the idea those and I
like that they're a little deeper than
the specialists because the specialists
were kind of again like the introduction
that idea they have the mobility and
everything from advanced warfare and
like earlier titanfall but right now I'm
not seeing too much creativity like when
I kind of want to at this point when
we're this close to release no no
because you have like we're talking in
like a few minutes about which shooter
is right for you coming out this fall I
mean we had do minore watch and you know
battle born earlier in the year but now
we have like another three which are all
kind of similar like military shooters
and you know you kind of have to set
yourself apart especially if your call
duty which releases every year people
are gonna buy it people are gonna like
it I'm sure it's gonna be it will
probably be decent from everything I've
played so far but I don't know I kind of
was hoping that we would see more in the
beta about them being creative
yeah I mean to your point it's like
we're pretty deep in the game now so I'm
pretty sure like what you saw on the
beta outside of like some like rig
balancing or weapon balancing is kind of
what you're going to get unless there's
more maps that we haven't seen which is
possible but I mean frontier is probably
like a decent example of like where they
could have messed with low grab a little
bit and they didn't write so I don't
know if they're going to innovate in
terms of that in terms of like maps and
stuff like that so I don't expect that
so much but you know it's another solid
cod game you the shootings like what it
what you would expect you know note like
very little recoil actions really fast
you get it back in like really quickly I
think that's kind of part of the allure
of playing cod I guess is that like even
if you dies like Amelie will get that
guy because I can respawn like right
away mm-hmm or is you know like what the
battlefield and some of these games
we're going to talk about later it's a
little bit different but it's definitely
interesting time with like these three
kind of like all futuristic shooters are
well sans battlefield but all the
shooters coming out like almost like
weeks after each other yeah to be
completely fair I had fun with call of
duty I don't know if I would want to
play it past that level 30 mark i think
is 30 the cap for the beta 30 is a cap
for the beta but i'm sure there's
probably more breast and again there's
there's another handful of maps we don't
even have access to right now we're
going to be able to probably see more
get more into the weapon crafting just
because we're playing with different
mission teams I've assume I think
there's only one unlocked right now or
two there's two okay so yeah I think
there are more than that don't call me
on that but yeah I'm looking forward to
it and again I'm kind of more curious
about the campaign at this point the
campaign is the one thing that you know
they said there's no loading screens
it's just like the seamless thing
there's either you're either taking off
from Earth to space or vice versa or
plan it to space don't know what planet
you go to or it's a cutscene which
sounds cool or you're in that hub ship
which sounds cool because if this if
it's this kind of I don't know how
they're gonna structure it but if it's
this seamless kind of thing that you're
just playing the whole time and not just
going oh mission 3 let's just replay
that that sounds like that could set
this game apart from like black ops 3
which had a pretty decent campaign
what's my favorite but I'm pretty
curious about single player has game
we're like any call duty game like that
doesn't sound linear at all which is
like totally the call of duty experience
yeah in the space combat I haven't tried
yet at all i don't think aside from
people that are like reviewing it
ostensibly i haven't touched that i
don't think anybody has
but yeah so that is called duty infinite
warfare the beta i believe is I think
it's either today or tomorrow it's open
for everybody on ps4 and that will be
you know like public now it won't just
be closed so more people be able play it
go up to level 30 and you guys will get
to try it out and let us know what you
think in the comments below